all right so let me walk you through how
this works and there are really three
rules that we're going to jot down and
then I'm going to invite you to try and
solve this with me collaboratively it's
on the top left hand corner gentleman
pinup and your book
it should be open thank you all right
now let me unpack the rules for you
thank you now someone said is this like
Sudoku it is like Sudoku in a very
particular way and I'm gonna explain
what that way is David thank you that's
the sixth time by the way I'm counting
in case you didn't know because as a
class at 11 past I know you had to get
here but that's not the time that I was
having an issue with it's once we get
here and knowing what to do and using
that time well I expect this is gonna be
something really fun and engaging but it
doesn't mean I don't watch it carefully
and still behave in a effective and
helpful way shall we start again yes
thank you all right this is a Japanese
puzzle okay
the English word for it by the way if
you want I don't know if it's a straight
translation I don't think it is but if
you google it you'll find this same
puzzle it's called unequal and that's
kind of the crux of the game I mentioned
before it's a bit like Sudoku in that
you can see this is a four by four
square so the numbers we're going to use
are one through four just take that page
ten over for a second you might notice
it's the same kind of puzzle but the
puzzles are each a different size how
big of those puzzles it's five across
five down so for those you're not going
to use numbers one through four you're
gonna use one through five and bigger
and bigger if you had bigger ones okay
so that's actually the first rule if you
like you're going to use the numbers and
I'm going to say 1 to n where m is the
size is the width or the height
of your puzzle so for the 4x4 it'll be 1
to 4 for the 5x5 it'll be 1 to 5 so you
use the numbers 1 to 5 the second rule
is again like pseudo key there are no
duplicate numbers in the rows or the
columns so we're using the numbers 1
through 4 in here right you can see the
2 that appears here means that there
isn't a true anywhere else in that row
and there isn't a true anywhere else in
that column yeah so far so good
okay now the last rule is the most
important one and it's where the puzzle
gets its name so you can see those
errors that are there on the board yeah
what the arrows indicate is the
relationships between two neighboring
cells and it just tells you which cell
is bigger let me say that again this
arrow just relates these two cells
together none of the other ones in the
column just for next door once the
neighboring cells and it tells you which
cell is bigger so neighboring cells are
related by size not all of them I should
point out you might notice they're not
errors going everywhere but there are
enough arrows along with these other
rules to work out everything that needs
to go in here so I'm going to start you
off nice and gentle I think you can all
tell me with the rules here what number
should go in this cell here look at look
at this right so look at which ones
bigger right so this is the bigger side
this is the smaller side so this cell is
smaller that means it's r1 okay very
good
so I've used that too and the ones so
far so good I want you to have a look at
this cell here see this one here look at
it carefully okay you got on your page
we can't be the two because we're here
we've got a two in that column can't be
the one because we have a one in that
row but it also can't be a four why not
yeah this cell is gonna be smaller than
that one right so this can't be the four
that means it's that three the only
number that can fill this cells bigger
than three so it's four have you look up
in here the column to finish it out
means there's our one okay keep on
looking have a look I'm gonna ask you at
this cell over here in a similar way to
this one
you can tell me what this number has to
be it has to be a three right because it
can't be one or two I've already use
them but it can't be a 4 coz it's
smaller than the one I mean so that
makes this a 3 and a 4 next to it
there's only one thing left in this row
right that's a 4 there's only one thing
left in here - very good
now you're like I have no more arrows
right so we have to use the other rules
of the game for instance I think you
should be able to tell me what this self
here is have a look carefully and look
at the whole board hmm what do you think
wait it's - how did she know Hayley
here's a to the bottom right right so
you can't put the 2 there that means the
2 was that in fact by the way just
before we put that at any point if
you've placed all of the numbers except
for one of them so see how I've got
three twos already on there there's only
one last spot that that two can go does
that make sense
lower self one what's here could this be
this has to be three Cantor husband
because um or can it be one this has to
be one doesn't it because I've used all
the other spots for one's yeah has to be
one right because I've got this one this
one this one yep so that makes this a
three what if I go left that's a three
and a four and we're finished